we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
cryptocurrency related suggestion that
came in via voicemail hey david i
recently seen you talking about your
interest in bitcoins or more broadly
cryptocurrency and i wanted to sort of
let you in on something where it's sort
of an idea that I have where instead of
having payments go through credit
processing go through uh YouTube in
Super chats and go through patreon
people could pay you in crypto
currencies right so I like the idea and
we've explored it and I have said in the
past that I'm sort of dabbling in
cryptocurrency I've been buying small
amounts of Bitcoin etherium and litecoin
for the last eight or nine months just
sort of dollar cost cost averaging in
not a big crypto player myself I
actually had a proposal done for
implementing at least Bitcoin if not
Bitcoin and etherium payments for
memberships the problem is right now
there is no way that I was told any way
to set up recurring payments with
cryptocurrency and the entire membership
system is based on recurring payments
and it's not reasonable to expect
someone who wants to pay six bucks a
month for membership in cryptocurrency
to remember on the same day of the month
to go in and manually send a Bitcoin
payment so that's the hump that I'm
trying to get over right now but I agree
I would love to be accepting
cryptocurrency and if someone in the
audience is really knowledgeable about
how we might implement something like
this within the system that we have
please let me know because I'd be super
interested in that on the bonus show
today you can exercise yourself to death
according to a new study Cairo has been
named the most dangerous mega city for
women and London the best mega city for
women and the idea of planting trees to
combat climate change earlier in the
week I talked about this a little bit
and we've got a sort of follow-up story
to that how do you get access to the
bonus show two ways number one
member at david pakman.com slash
membership number to become a patron at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
we'll speak to you on the bonus show